in your mind why is the supreme court
important well the supreme court is
important for the original founders
reasons or that it was it was like all
american institutions there were ideas
the founders had and then
john marshall an important justice
created the office by the practice of
the office and
it is important because the court is
where america's thorniest questions go
to be resolved they haven't been
resolved in the executive branch and the
legislative branch and so the court has
to take them up and that is where the
court goes back to those first
principles again why we study american
history what exactly was the outline for
how the country is supposed to behave
and are we staying within that outline
in those series of ideals it goes back
to the very beginning ingredients of
america so the court is a test always of
whether what we're doing now is in
keeping with what we were supposed to do
at the founding of the country the
reason it has become so important
recently is that the court
ends up doing a lot more than it was
ever supposed to do because of weakness
in the executive branch and the
legislative branch and so a lot of
people are now looking to the court to
solve problems that should actually be
handled by the people's representatives
the judges are not elected they are in
there for life at the supreme court
through the process of the president
with advice and consent by the senate
but they are not elected and this was
supposed to be a republic in which the
elected representatives were the ones
making the laws but that's we've shifted
away from that and so the court is now
making decisions that can affect
people's lives for a generation and not
be changed
as easily as say a piece of legislation
which can be vetoed amended
superseded by another piece of
legislation it's really
permanent changes in the american life
so my understanding is that the supreme
court should be above politics to what
degree is that actually the case well
the supreme court has had lots of
interest there have been times where the
supreme court when andrew jackson was
president he tried to use the supreme
court to do what he wanted it to do and
and franklin delano roosevelt tried to
change the
the uh functioning of the court because
it kept knocking down all of his all the
things he wanted to do we've had moments
where there have been these spasms where
presidents have tried to get the court
to do what they wanted but in general it
was the american tradition that the
justices were supposed to be picked if
they were of good character and if they
were of sound legal mind if they had
views on the on the matters related to
the constitution that were sort of sound
legally but their politics weren't
supposed to be so important
what has happened is like so much in
modern american life is there has been
an intertwining of politics and and the
legal profession so that now when
presidents run for office they say elect
me so that i can put in our kinds of
judges which means that the kind of
judge you pick helps you with your
voters and if your voters want a very
specific kind of ideological judge then
the more ideological of the judge that
you pick the greater your voters will be
happy about you and that'll keep you in
office
and that is true of the senators
advising and consenting on these
decisions and true of the presidents who
pick them well that means that the
people who go into the office
into the supreme court i should say end
up being more political than in the past
there was a period where when amer when
an american president would pick a
justice that justice very often would
rule in a way that was totally the
opposite of what the members of that
president's party wanted it happened
repeatedly in american life and that was
a symbol people thought of the idea that
these these issues before the court were
being weighed on their merits and had
nothing to do with the ideological views
of the judge weighing them now
where you sit on a particular issue is
often determined by where you came from
politically
you